three amazing health benefits of
quadriceps mushroom quadriceps is a
fungus that grows on the larvae of
certain insects in high altitude regions
of Asia it has been used in traditional
Chinese medicine for centuries for its
numerous health benefits quadriceps
mushroom has anti-aging effects as it is
a rich source of antioxidants which
protect ourselves from damage caused by
free radicals it also contains a
compound called quadriceepin which has
been shown to have anti-aging effects in
vitro and in animal studies quadriceps
mushroom can help to boost the immune
system and protect against infection by
increasing the production of white blood
cells and cytokines quadriceps mushroom
also contains a compound called
adenosine which has been shown to have
immune boosting properties quadriceps
mushroom can also help to improve heart
health in a number of ways it can help
to lower cholesterol levels reduce
inflammation and protect against heart
disease quadriceps mushroom also
contains a compound called quarter sepic
acid which has been shown to have cardio
productive effects in animal studies
check out the description box to know
how to include quadriceps in your diet
remember to stay curious and stay
healthy